sometimes bad things horrible things
happen to good people
and I don't I don't know why but life
isn't fair that that's what that's the
reality and disease like cancer in MS
and horrible diseases and accidents and
these things a good person in the wrong
place in the wrong time can end up just
a victim of fate and end of reality and
it can be horrible and heart-wrenching
but when those bad things happen to
people around you what are you going to
do how are you going to lead are you
going to get angry are you going to get
frustrated are you gonna lash out at
people who are you going to lash out at
anyways are you going to start going
down the spiral of negativity or are you
going to let this horrible situation
dictate the way you feel and the way you
handle it are you gonna fall over fall
down and fall apart
or or are you going to lead are you
going to face this issue with courage
it was resolution I say lead lead step
up to the challenge be the one that
other people look to absorb that impact
absorb that negativity draw fire draw
fire that's that's what a member of a
platoon for for tactical reasons steps
into the open to draw enemy fire maybe
to give another part of his team the
chance to move or or distract the enemy
but that's what I say draw fire bring
that pain to me I can handle it when
when maybe others cannot and when when
bad things are happening I am going to
try and be the one good thing the thing
standing tall that can be relied upon
because I know that that attitude will
spread it will bolster those around me
and and we will fight and in fighting we
will win and if not the battle and if
not the war we will win because our
spirit it will never surrender in that
that is the ultimate victory to hold
your head high and even even in the face
of inescapable defeat
to stand and to fight that is the wind